lunch money time let's get after it
what's going on today in the world whoa
that was fast well let's go why don't
you ever say like get your lunch money
right anymore while wall street's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get our lunch money right it's a
reading test to see if the audience is
reading the bottom here which says while
wall street is trying to get rich the
rest of us are just trying to get lunch
money right
hey you pay attention here we go okay
ready
the today the federal reserve is widely
expected to raise
its fed funds target rate by a half
percentage points
point point not points but investors are
worried why are investors worried well
the first thing is that obviously the
fed flooded the market with cheap
capital over the last two years or so
they literally just were printing cash
left and right the elected officials
were handing out fiscal policy like it
was candy and all they were doing was
stuffing it in every exotic corner the
financial system they were sending 1200
checks they were going ahead and buying
all sorts of different assets anywhere
they could possibly try to stimulate the
economy they were doing it that also
included the cutting of interest rates
you remember back in march of 2020 in
april they had two emergency rate cuts
down to a zero percent rate environment
that meant cheap capital for everyone
when you start to think about that then
you get into this world where you say to
yourself all right if there's going to
be cheap capital i'm going to go borrow
money i'm going to go and i'm going to
invest and so that's exactly what people
did now as asset prices exploded as
inflation took off etc the fed's sitting
there oh buddy we are two years into
this game i cannot let us go ahead and
keep having this high inflation so what
are they gonna do they've got to start
to tighten and it means that they're
going to stop doing the asset purchases
they're going to go ahead and start
raising interest rates they're going to
raise the 25 basis points but the stock
market said oh no more cheap capital and
just falling out of the sky people are
losing money tiger global down over 40
percent year-to-date many other hedge
funds also suffering massive losses uh
as well now the key to this is that the
market is pricing in this afternoon we
are going to get a 50 basis point rate
hike we'll go from 0.25 to 0.75 percent
the only problem with that is if they
continue to do it all of a sudden then
we are going to have to see
what will occur what is going to happen
if they go ahead and they raise the 75
basis points will the market sell off
more or not nobody knows but remember in
q1 there was a economic contraction
meaning that we actually had negative
growth in q1 and if the fed continues to
raise interest rates into an economic
issue
that ain't good it just gets real bad
from there i don't know what do you
think
i think that i honestly i have no
opinion on this i'm just confused why
they haven't done this
before why why now
why didn't they already do this well
because again
they're cycles right so basically the
whole idea is that uh stock prices were
crashing everything was crashing in
march of 2020 oh [ __ ] we got to step in
we have to feel like we have some sort
of control let's step in when we step in
drop interest rates print money that was
the whole playbook stock market comes
flying back economy's good but still
unemployment was high there's all kinds
of issues oh supply chains inflation's
transitory all the nonsense they were
telling everyone and so just until the
end of 2021 they're like maybe inflation
isn't transitory but my question is did
they know that they would have to do
this or are they doing it because they
can't stop
there are constant cycles where they
know that they need to stimulate the
economy which is quantitative easing and
then there are points where they need to
do quantitative tightening the problem
is normally when they are doing
quantitative tightening it is because
they are doing it before the recession
comes we are in a recession right now a
recession is two consecutive quarters of
gdp uh gdp contraction we will get the
gdp contraction in q2 i believe and so
we are already in the recession it's
just that now they're starting so late
with the quantitative tightening and
it's why i continue to always say like
you can get inflation or you can get um
a recession pick your poison in some
crazy way we have recession and
inflation at the same time double whammy
not good for anybody in the economy
all right ready let's go
hester pierce purse
oh purse yeah only because she's
corrected me before i learn i learned
from experience
it wasn't spelled pierce the normal way
so personally it makes sense okay so so
hester per she's a member of the sec um
is she a former commissioner uh i
believe she is a commissioner she is the
commissioner she is a commissioner
there's multiple commissioners in the
sec yes okay
the sec
uh is going to increase the head count
to 50 people for their like cyber crime
unit so they're going to be more on the
regulatory front they want to
get you know cryptocrime out of the way
she tweeted the sec is a regulatory
agency with an enforcement division not
an enforcement agency why are we leading
with enforcement in crypto
but she's a member so why didn't she
just tell them she's been very pro
bitcoin very pro crypto uh over time and
basically the whole idea is uh
regulation through enforcement would be
the whole uh uh kind of mechanism where
i'm not gonna tell you what the rules
are you go and do something and then i
show back up later i'm like oh you broke
the rules like we're gonna enforce on
you and that sets the precedent for
future rules now there's two sides to
this argument very important to call out
two sides the first side is uh there are
entrepreneurs and investors who are
saying we want to build stuff in this
industry tell us what the rules are so
that we can go do it now the other side
of it is people saying the rules already
exist if you commit a crime you're going
to jail you're being fined if you're a
fraud then you're going to get caught et
cetera and so when you start to think
about that it ends up being this really
really
and there's a third side of okay people
who are like oh there's no rules that
it's kind of a gray area so i'm going to
do whatever i want and those are the
nefarious actors correct it's not always
people trying to do the right thing yes
but but the and the thing is if you're a
bad actor you're going to get caught
like if you're sitting there and you are
breaking the law you're committing fraud
whatever that's pretty easy they're
gonna find you the second thing that
ends up being the issue is this idea of
let's say that you don't believe that
you're issuing a security but they deem
you are issuing a security
you could sit and wait for them to come
up with the rules but people have been
waiting for years now and so what
becomes really really nuanced and hard
is let's say i'll use a really kind of
egregious example uh let's say that
there are rules that say an exchange has
to file xyz paperwork with the regulator
and every centralized exchange coinbase
or whatever they go and they file xyz
paperwork now all of a sudden a
decentralized exchange comes along well
if it's truly decentralized big if but
if it is truly decentralized what is the
regulatory treatment how do they do it
because technically the software code
you can't put it in jail you can't
financially find it it's decentralized
so you get in this weird situation where
uh there's just a lot of nuance and no
one's yet talking about how to solve
that so some entrepreneurs push forward
and build and say we'll figure it out
later
others don't
and that's where this debate comes in
but i think what the sec is doing is
saying like oh we're gonna enforce and
that's how we're gonna come up with the
rules and that's where she's saying
maybe we shouldn't do that maybe we
should come out with the rules we should
uh clearly articulate what they are and
then we should go ahead and do
enforcement if somebody breaks the rules
we've already told them exist is a
member of the sec can't she influence
them
yes but she doesn't have a
soul discretion she's not unilaterally
able to do that it ends up being a
situation where she's one of many
members she's definitely been the bull
for quite a while now she's literally
known as crypto mom uh but but she can't
go ahead and do it herself and so that's
where she's basically using her public
platform to say hey i i'm dissented
right it's kind of like when the supreme
court comes out and says hey we voted on
something there's somebody that uh that
goes ahead and says this is what the uh
the pro argument is and somebody says
this is the dissenting argument and then
the public can see even though the vote
went one way there's still a dissenting
argument okay
starbucks said it will hike wages for
tenured workers and double training for
new employees as the company and ceo
howard schultz seek to beat back the
union push from its baristas
cervix is going to spend 1
billion on this to train
wage hikes and training so the wage
hikes they have to do or they won't be
able to compete uh mcdonald's right now
20 an hour is pretty much the going rate
for somebody to work at a fast food
joint so if you're starbucks is it at
mcdonald's mcdonald's definitely has 20
an hour and maybe not every single
location but in
many many locations around the country
uh and it's just because there's
competition right is uh if i'm
mcdonald's i'm competing with all the
other fast food restaurants i'm
competing with gig work i'm competing
with all these other things i have to as
a free market participant i have to
increase the price i'm willing to pay
people or they won't come work here i
offer ten dollars nobody shows up i
offer 12 nobody shows up 15. nobody
shows up it's all up to 20
amazon 20 an hour etc so starbucks has
to increase uh compensation for
employees or they won't be able to
actually get people then the second
thing that ends up happening is the
training if you think about starbucks
like their entire business is based on
having a system that works uh perfectly
you need to have uh the same experience
when you walk in you need to have the
same quality and you have all stuff like
that's all training and so to build the
systems and then roll that out costs
money and so it makes sense i'm
surprised that they aren't already doing
this and a billion dollars feels like
it's really not that much money in the
grand scheme of things yeah but
starbucks is one of those companies
that's known for things like this right
not just training but like
paying for college and tuition and books
for it's uh because they have to do they
have to i don't think they have to if
they stop doing that stuff they won't be
able to hire anyone
but starbucks is like do you want to go
work at starbucks no
do i want to work at starbucks no people
why is that relevant because
if most people if you go and talk and
say do you want to work at starbucks
they say no then you say okay well what
if starbucks pays you 20 an hour maybe
then they say and what if they pay for
uh your college okay maybe right like
all they're doing is they're trying to
increase the number of things that they
can offer to people it's all about
compensation and perks now there are
some people who's like yo i love
starbucks i want to work there it's the
it's my dream job right but that
percentage of population is very small
so how do you expand on top of funnel
this is all business ends up being it's
about incentives what is the incentive
for have somebody come and work at your
business of course increase the
incentive increase the pay increase the
compensation increase the benefits and
then you'll be able to attract more
people and that's exactly what starbucks
is doing totally one time we went to a
starbucks in bali and i was not expect
what yeah i remember this experience why
we walked a long way through the rice
fields yeah we were doing the real uh uh
what do they call like uh the real on
the ground experience of bali we went to
starbucks no well that was just one time
okay yeah um but but i was somebody and
then a dog almost attacked you oh my god
guys all right come on let's keep going
okay okay okay but i was just gonna say
it's it's a very uniform experience you
know
i couldn't hear my headphones they fixed
it sorry oh is that what yeah planet was
shook there jordy was crawling it was
like a lot over here that's what we do
for you guys trying to be normal go
ahead okay i'm good now i'm good oh okay
got a text message here
so twitter
twitter circle twitter circle is
something that twitter is testing it's
gonna be kind of like the close friends
feature on instagram where you can send
messages just to like or photos whatever
you can instagram just your close
friends yep um so twitter is doing that
where if you tweet something only your
close friends can see it do we like this
i the whole point listen twitter twitter
stop it stop the madness stop the
madness stop trying to copy everyone
else you wanna know what twitter needs
to do twitter needs to go to every
politician every journalist and say
you're off the platform done you're
kicked off the platform oh you wanna
come back is this important to your
business
if if this is important to your business
if this is important to your campaign
pays a thousand dollars a month that's
what they should do how many politicians
how many journalists would pay a
thousand dollars a month to use twitter
every single one of them it is the
single most important platform if you're
a journalist or a politician
and if twitter wants to go ahead and
make money don't do twitter circle don't
do this or that like leave the average
person alone just say you guys use this
for free but if you're a politician if
you're a journalist a thousand dollars a
month
and i promise you you know what's gonna
happen all the morons who are just on
the internet screwing around they're not
gonna pay the thousand dollars
but
the journalists yeah every media
organization is gonna pay the thousands
of course
of course and now all of a sudden you
have a relationship with a journalist
where they don't get on there and act
like fools now all of a sudden you're
paying us to be on here you're gonna go
literally siphon the twitter traffic to
go make money on your website pace a
thousand dollars a month if you're a
politician you're going to literally
become one of the most influential
people in america pay us a thousand
dollars okay but how
sorry how are they gonna regulate that
like you can't
you know well it's easy if i want to
watch netflix i have to pay them every
month if i don't pay them i don't get a
watch if they don't pay the money then
they don't get to use the platform yeah
but i can link create another account
and just be like i'm a politician what
are they going to say trust me they'll
figure it out if you create a offering
where as a politician or as a journalist
you need to pay a thousand dollars a
month that again i'm not a genius but
that's twelve thousand dollars a year
for every single journalist at the new
york times every single journalist at
the washington post every single
journalist at msnbc and fox and whatever
other service that you want leave the
average person alone make them feel
special so y'all gotta use this [ __ ] for
free y'all cool
politicians and journalists you're
paying
okay but can i ask one ask whatever you
want
can i ask how they're supposed to make
money on twitter circles they're not
trying to make money with twitter circle
from my understanding all they're trying
to do is they're basically trying to
instagram they're trying to create a uh
a better environment uh
in terms of being able to only talk to a
small group of your friends and the idea
here is like maybe you don't want to
blast it to everybody right sure maybe
but at the end of the day twitter's
value proposition in my opinion is the
connectivity to the audience it is the
ability to reach people i don't know or
go talk to other people or whatever and
so ultimately i think that's what they
end up missing here is that this is
looking at another product like uh okay
let's do like a me too version oh they
have close friends let's do twitter
circle sure maybe some people use it
maybe they don't whatever but like this
is not gonna be a mainstream feature
because the whole value proposition of
twitter is one to many communication how
do i go yes but here's mine to the world
if elon musk is all about free speech
and he's gonna do all this stuff you
can't
pick and choose who you want to pay
because that's not really a public
square as he calls it
yeah you can do whatever you want free
speech
has nothing to do with whether i get i
let you listen to me or not
if you let me listen so if i block you
has nothing to do with free speech
right it's not freedom to listen it is
free speech this is not it's also not
freedom to pay like you should be able
to as anybody go on the public square
and except if you're a politician or if
you're a journalist by the way they
should make the president united states
pay a million dollars a year
a million dollars if you're the head of
a state a million bucks i would even
argue that maybe if you're in the senate
or congress you got to pay more than a
thousand dollars a month like just let's
start ratcheting it up how what is it
worth to these people yeah the president
of the united states they're gonna pay a
lot of money you may be able to get 10
million dollars out of them oh
so let's start playing the game how much
is it worth jack up the cost make it
free for everybody else get rid of all
the crypto spam all the bots all this
nonsense just start leveling in bots are
pretty crazy guys exactly what it costs
all right what's next okay so do you
guys remember the uh the game wordle the
one that the new york times bought for
several million dollars which no what is
this
um you know this game
where you have to guess a word and
several tries
i wouldn't need several tries go ahead
you didn't need someone trying to be
played did i play it yes um so you
played it once used to me
but then
when that game went viral this other
game that's also called wordle
accidentally got the benefit because a
bunch of people started downloading the
wrong well wrong version on the app
store uh smart so now it's getting
bought by app lovin it's a game maker in
an undisclosed deal but they're buying
this because of the crazy traction it
got thanks to this other game seo
yeah but it's crazy why is it so crazy
because
if you really think about it benefited
from somebody else's success
no they set themselves up for success
they picked the name wordle
and that just happened to be perfectly
positioned so that when the other one
took off they took off it's how you
benefit from my success oh i'm just so
successful i leave a trail that key do
you have any questions from the audience
no questions
do you want everyone to leave their
question in the comments of the video so
that you can pick one for tomorrow yes
but that's what i've been saying okay
we'll say it oh yeah leave your question
for lunch but it's a little confusing
because okay
ask lm in the comments below on this
video or in the separate lunch money
video that gets posted just
leave your questions we'll answer them
that's it